Two one.
Yeah.
And we're live. All right.
So to set this up, um,
when Gary was on last,
Gary Tobbs Still Stefan,
how do I say your last name? Stephanie.
DNA. DNA. DNA. It's like DNA,
like DNA with a g.
Right. Got It. Okay. Um,
when you were on last, Stephan had, uh,
some opposition to some of the
things that you were saying.
We talked about getting
him on and you on together.
We finally pulled it off.
Took there was a lot of wrangling was a
lot of back and forth and cat wrangling,
but we got it. We're here. Um,
give me your position on this
is all for folks listening,
this is all about obesity and the,
the mechanism for obesity,
is that fair to say?
Yeah. Yeah. So essentially, uh,
the main points that we
want to talk about today,
I'll try to keep this a fist from your
face just so you can move it around. Um,
what causes obesity and what
causes insulin resistance,
which is behind a lot of our, um, chronic
diseases that are common in society.
And please, uh, give us
your background. Yeah.
So I have a,
a BS in biochemistry,
Phd in neuroscience.
After getting my phd in neuroscience,
I went on to study the neuroscience of
obesity at the University of Washington
and particularly the brain circuits
that regulate body fatness.
Hopefully we'll get a chance
to talk about those today.
And then I went on to
become a science consultant,
science communicator and write a book
called the hungry brain. That is,
um, my attempt to explain for a
non specialist audience what, uh,
what causes obesity and uh,
yeah, so that's my background.
Now, what is your disagreement
with Gary's position? Everything.
Everything. Yeah. So, uh, how about,
how about I just can I start by explaining
please do what I believe caused the
obesity. I'm going to be long winded here.
Is that okay? Go right ahead. All right.
We have ours. Okay, cool. So first,
uh, a little bit of housekeeping,
I'm going to be citing a lot of
evidence today and so I was wanting,
he's bringing this up to you. Okay,
sure. Just moving around. Sure, sure.
You want to sit back? How's that?
Perfect. Okay. I'm going to be exciting.
A lot of evidence today and I want people
to be able to follow along at home and
so I've put many of the references that
I'm going to be siting on doesn't cover
your face. Okay, there we go. All right.
I've put a lot of the references that
I'm going to be siting on my website,
Stephan bna.com or if you don't
feel like spelling my name,
you can go to whole health source.org and
I have a numbered list of topics there
and I'm going to be calling out numbers.
Just scroll down to the number that I
referred to and the references are all
there. The second thing I want to say, uh,
that I would want to be really clear
about today is that I'm not here to be the
anti low carb guy. Okay. Um,
I think low carb diets are valid
tool for a controlling body,
fatness and controlling blood sugar.
I'm not here to talk anybody out
of being on a low carb diet. Um,
what I am here to try to talk people
out of is some of the mythology that has
accumulated around the low carb diet.
Okay?
So I want to get started with an
analogy to help people understand, um,
why the brain is important and obesity.
So imagine you're an alien coming
down from outer space and you want to
understand what's going on on earth.
And you notice that on the highway some
cars are traveling faster than others.
Some cars go faster, some cars go
slower and you want to figure out why.
And so you go and you start studying the
tires of the cars because obviously the
amount of force that is exerted by the
tire onto the asphalt is the thing that
determines the speed of the car.
We know this, this is just physics.
And so you study the tires and you study
the tires and you study them and you
never figure out why some cars go
faster than others. Now, why is that?
The reason is that you're studying
the wrong part of the system.
If you want to understand the,
uh,
why some cars go faster than others,
you have to understand the part of
the system that regulates speed.
And that is the person behind the wheel.
And so in this analogy,
the tires are fat cells and the
person behind the wheel is the brain.
There has been tons of
research on fat cell biology,
on what factors put fat in fat cells,
what take it out.
It's been tons and tons
of research on that.
And it's intuitively obvious that we
should be studying that to understand
obesity, right? But in fact,
all of that research has yielded very
little insight into why some people are
fatter than, than others. That's because
it's the wrong part of the system.
Study fat cells do not regulate the size
of fat cells anymore than the tires on
a car regulate the,
the speed of the car.
The thing that regulates the size of fat
cells is the brain. So let's talk about,
um, first of all, give you a little
framework for thinking about this.
The brain evolved over about 600 million
years to promote the survival and
reproduction of our ancestors.
And over the course of that time,
we evolved all of these different brain
circuits that have specialized functions.
They generate our hunger and our
cravings and our fullness feelings.
They generate our eating behavior,
what and how much we eat.
And they actively regulate the
amount of fat on our bodies.
And that's one of the
things I want to talk about.
And all of these circuits evolved.
And these are nonconscious by the way.
So you don't decide.
You want to be hungry,
you don't decide that you
want to have a craving.
These are things that bubble up from
nonconscious parts of your brain that you
don't control. So, um,
these circuits are calibrated to
an environment of our ancestors,
not the environment that
we're living in right now.
So these circuits all evolved to function
optimally in the environment of our
ancestors. Pr Promote the survival
and reproduction of our ancestors.
So what happens when you put these
brain circuits in the modern environment
where you have abundant
calorie, dense, tasty foods,
rich in carbohydrate and fat is these
same brain circuits push us to over
consume and they push our bodies
to accumulate and hold on to fat.
And then what you see as a result
is the three hallmarks of obesity.
First of all, the obvious, you see
elevated body fat mass. Second of all,
you see elevated calorie intake.
People with obesity consume more calories
than people who do not have obesity
after correcting for height and
sex and physical activity level.
And third,
you see that people with obesity defend
their higher level of body fatness
against changes. And so there's actually
a regulatory change that happens.
It's not conscious defense,
you know,
they're not trying to remain obese.
It's these body fat regulatory circuits.
And this is where Gary gets it right,
is that people with obesity are not
just lean. People who eat more calories.
There's actually a change
in the regulatory activity
that regulates body fat in
the body.
And we can get back to how that happens,
but I'll just leave it there for now.
So up until this point,
I've basically just been telling
a plausible story, right? I mean,
I haven't actually cited any
evidence yet to support that.
My story is correct. Um,
and so let's get into that.
Let's talk about what some of the evidence
is that supports this idea that I've
just laid out. So I
want to start with, um,
the genetics of obesity.
I think this offers some wit.
[inaudible] uh, as long as it's
very brief. The question I don't,
I still don't quite understand
what the model is. Okay.
Now I have to say about this.
How about environment?
If you don't understand the model,
how about I lay out,
how about I finish laying it out and
then you can ask a question because I may
answer your question over the
course of a continuing. So let me,
let me just finish. Um, okay.
So now the genetics of obesity offers
us a lot of insight into the biological
mechanisms that drive differences in
body fatness in the general population.
So you get these studies,
like the,
the most interesting studies or the
Genome Wide Association studies.
They get hundreds of thousands
of people together and they, um,
sequence or they measure all these markers
in their genomes and they figure out
what parts of the genome makes
some people fatter than another.
So if you have version a in
this particular location,
you end up a little fatter
than if you have version B.
And when you look at all the
places where this is happening,
you can see the genes where it's
happening in. And that tells you,
if you look at what those genes are doing,
that tells you what the mechanisms are
that underlie everyday differences in
body fatness, in the general population.
And so to kind of warm ourselves up,
let's start by talking about height genes.
So height has a strong genetic component.
So does body fatness,
um,
and researchers as figured out a lot of
the genes that underlie differences in
height between people.
And when you look at what those genes do,
they tend to be involved in the growth
and development of the skeleton and the
connective tissue, which is
what you would expect, right?
Cause growth of the skeleton
determines your height.
So genes that determine diabetes risk
type two diabetes are all about insulin
sensitivity,
all about insulin secretion
and the function of the
insulin secreting pancreas,
which is what you expect because
diabetes is a disease that is all about
insulin. So these studies are really good
at getting at the underlying biological
mechanisms that are
driving these phenomena.
So what do these studies
had to say about obesity?
If Gary's model is correct,
we should see a bunch of genes popping
up related to fat cells and insulin.
If my model is correct,
we should see a bunch of genes popping
up related to the brain. And in fact,
that's exactly what we see.
The genetics of obesity are overwhelmingly
related to differences in brain
activity between individuals.
And um,
okay so that's one piece of evidence.
Another piece of evidence.
There are five FDA
approved weight loss drugs.
Four of those act in the brain.
One of them reduces dietary fat
absorption in the digestive tract.
There are no effective fat
loss drugs that I'm aware of.
The target insulin or fat cells.
Third piece of evidence. Um,
if you look at,
some people get really unlucky in life
and they end up with these horrible
genetic mutations that, you know,
knock out some biological pathways.
Some of these people end up with
extreme obesity people and also animals.
We see this in mice and rats.
Just occasionally you get unlucky
and you get really, really fat.
And researchers have been
cataloging what are these mutations?
When we find people who are
genetically really obese,
what are these mutations
that are making them fat?
What is the biological mechanism that's
getting screwed up that's making them
fat?
And what they've found is that all of
these mutations that they've identified to
date,
a number of them are occurring
in the Leptin signaling pathway.
And this is the Leptin,
um,
is the primary fat regulating
hormone in the body.
Gary avoids this,
never talks about this in his writing,
but Leptin as the primary fat
regulating hormone in the body.
And these mutations
either knock out Leptin,
they knock out leptin receptors or they
knock out the left and response pathway
in the brain. And um, so that's
the third piece of evidence.
Okay.
So now we haven't really gotten around
to talking about what it is exactly about
the bad interaction that happens between
our ancient brains in the modern food
environment that causes us to become fat.
Um,
we've established that the
brain is central to obesity,
but we haven't really established what
it is exactly about that interaction.
Why does our modern food, why does our
modern environment promote obesity?
Right.
So I'm basically,
there are three different ways that
I'm going to look at this from,
um,
but first I want to say that the,
probably the best way to answer this
question is to start with the question,
what is the most fattening
diet in the world?
What is the Diet that is more fattening
than any others in the answer to that is
it's human junk food in a variety
of nonhuman species and humans.
It's human junk food that is
more fattening than any others.
And I'm going to skip over some of the
research here that demonstrates this.
By the way, I haven't been
calling out numbers here. Okay,
let me call out some numbers.
Um,
reference number two on my website is,
um,
those genetic studies.
Reference number one is the obesity drugs.
Reference number six, is those
spontaneously occurring genetic mutations?
And now I'm talking about reference
number 52. So I'm, I'm gonna,
I'm going to gloss over some of the
individual research cause I'm being long
winded here.
But um,
essentially what you find is that this
stuff is really fattening and animals,
many different species. It's super
fattening and humans calorie dense.
When you put create an environment
with abundant easy calorie, dense,
tasty foods,
rich carbs and fat,
you see this dramatic overconsumption in
fact game across many species including
humans.
And what you find in the research is that
the sugar and the carbohydrate cannot
explain that they're part of the
effect. Yes, they explained part of it.
But you cannot replicate that effect
by only feeding sugar and carbohydrate.
You can't replicate it in animals.
You can't replicate it in humans.
When you say you can't replicate it,
you mean you can't replicate obesity?
What do you mean? Yeah. Um,
that's right. You cannot,
you cannot cause the
same degree of fat gain.
The same extent of fat gain,
the same extent of overconsumption using
only sugar and carbohydrate that you
can cause with a variety of calorie dense,
palatable human foods. You can't fully
replicate it with sugar and carbs.
You cannot fully replicate
it with fat alone either.
If you put those when we can, we can get
deeper in this if you want. I'm confused.
So you're,
you're saying that the,
the Diet that causes the most
obesity is what we think, right?
This a human junk food diversion,
sugar, simple carbs, bullshit,
bullshit type right.
What do you,
you're saying that you can't
replicate that with just,
you cannot fully replicated in some,
what I mean is that if you just feed,
if you just increase sugar
intake in animals or in humans,
you do get weight gain.
But it is modest compared to what you
get when you put people around a variety
of calorie dense, palatable foods,
rich in carbohydrates and fat.
Similarly, if that's very
confusing. How's that?
Because I'm not sure exactly what
you're saying. You're saying you,
if you give people this calorie
rich sugar diet of junk food,
you will make them gain weight
but not as much weight as what?
Um,
so what I'm saying is that if you,
if you give people or animals the,
the actual human junk food with all
the carbs and fat and everything,
they gain a lot more weight and a lot
faster than if you just give them a diet
that's high in sugar and
high in refined carbohydrate.
And what that shows is that the sugar and
they're fine carbohydrate cannot fully
explain the effect. Can't fully
explain why those foods are fattening.
See this is where I'm confused. No, I
don't see what you're saying cause you're,
you're saying if you give people
the Diet of American junk food,
you,
you get not as much of an effect if
you give them just the sugar and the
carbohydrates. So you're saying, Yep. So,
but what are you giving them when you're
giving them the g the Diet of junk food.
You give them.
For example,
in animals now it's different because
if you think about human junk foods,
generally those foods contain fat and
carbohydrate and salt and all kinds of
other things, so it's more, it's more
than just let's a lot of soda, no
sugar, so I'll get in more detail.
So the ways that you can do this,
you can add sugar,
just sugar table sugar to the feet
of animals. That's one way to do it.
Or you can add it to their drinking water.
Sometimes it's a little bit fattening,
sometimes it's not. It's not that
fattening and animals and humans,
you can ask them to drink sugar sweetened
beverages that are just sugar and you
can see what happens and people will
gain weight or you can tell them to stop
drinking sugar sweetened beverages
and you could see what happens.
People will gain weight,
they will lose weight.
Suggesting that that is
part of the explanation,
but it's a much smaller effect than you
see with this full pallet of these foods
that contain carbs and fat and all of
this other stuff. Desire saying car.
Well obviously there's
more calories right?
If there's carbs and fat and
all these other, correct.
If you think that calories matter, then we
agree. Oh, hold for short matters. Right?
Gary doesn't think it matters.
You don't think it matters. Well,
we think it's the wrong
way to think about it.